bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo comme chaque
vendredi nous faisons le point sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
au sommaire de cette édition le début du
baccalauréat
c'est ce lundi 18 juin avec l'épreuve de
philosophie
cette année près de 19 mille lycéens
vont passer cet examen dans les yvelines
nous avons suivi les dernières révisions
reportage à suivre dans cette édition
un an après ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale nous recevons
bruno myle yens il est député de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines avec lui
nous évoquerons les propos d' emmanuel
macron concernant les aides sociales
nous aborderons aussi la loi élan sur le
logement votée cette semaine et les
questions agricoles puis dans le reste
de l'actualité
nous reviendrons sur les inondations
dans les yvelines et sur l'engouement
des supporters de l'équipe de france
alors que la coupe du monde de football
vient de débuter en russie mais pour
commencer la grève à la sncf devrait se
poursuivre en juillet la cgt cheminots a
annoncé ce matin la prolongation du
mouvement
de leur côté la cfdt et l'unsa ne
suivront pas cette mobilisation
en attendant la grève se poursuit
dimanche 17 et lundi 18 juin pour éviter
tout retard au travail ou les épreuves
du baccalauréat
pensez à vérifier si vos trains
circuleront une information que vous
trouverez la veille de votre trajet à
partir de 17 heures sur le site
transilien.com enfin pour être complet
sur la grève à la sncf si vous êtes
détenteurs d'un pass navigo d'une carte
imagine r vous pourrez adresser votre
demande de remboursement à partir du 19
juin sur le site mon dédommagement point
transilien.com utiliser le numérique
pour mieux se former c'est le thème
cette année des rencontres de la
formation tout au long de la vie
organisé par saint quentin en yvelines
élu vs q la journée d'hier avait
notamment pour but de mieux comprendre
comment les entreprises de notre
territoire
ça pour pid s'approprient les outils
numériques pour former leurs
collaborateurs
plusieurs projets d'innovation
pédagogique porté par l'ue vs
qu ont également été présentés propos
recueillis par aurélie rose et patrick
jacques de dixmude l'université
évidemment demeurer au 15 novembre la
joue et nous avons démarré mais nous
avons besoin de l'expérience de ce lien
entre les acteurs privés les acteurs
publics les acteurs territoriaux les
acteurs économiques pour permettre
d'expérience de tous pour valoriser la
formation pour permettre la formation
tout au long de la vie c'est à dire
permettre que ce soit des employés des
cas des dirigeants de pouvoir monter en
compétences et le numérique et
innovations pédagogiques sont au coeur
des outils qui permettent cette montée
en compétences on reste sur la
thématique éducation le baccalauréat
commencent ce lundi 19 mille lycéens
yvelinois vont se pencher sur la
première épreuve la philosophie
les candidats se sont préparés pour
l'examen durant toute la semaine à saint
quentin en yvelines
certains ont révisé encadré ou entre
amis un reportage de camille lambert et
toki nirhy lanto de façon de réviser
pour un même objectif le baccalauréat au
centre alfred de vigny à voisins le
bretonneux ambiance petit comité
tout ce qui traite des nombres complexes
avec les numéros des baquets les numéros
des exercices donc talent point un
exercice 3 eurêka c'est l'opération de
soutien scolaire mise en place par
l'association de petits groupes de
travail accompagnés par des professeurs
c'est des stages de six heures donc
c'est trois séances de deux heures
l'activité ici un vrai cas commencent à
faire au centre alfred et vini a
commencé non on a commencé le 28 août
avec les stages de prérentrée puis on a
fait toute l'année scolaire
ici les élèves sont aidés en français en
physique ou en mathématiques
eureka semble bien accueillie c'était
pour bien acquérir les dernières notion
ce qui manque est comblé les petites
lacunes du défunt à montigny le
bretonneux soutien amical
jules en terminale s a choisi de réviser
avec ses amis donc été donné par action
il les retrouve tous les jours dans une
bibliothèque
objectif réaliser la physique une
épreuve qui compte coefficient 9
on est beaucoup plus productif à
plusieurs en fait il ya toute une
ambiance tout ça donc
alors on peut discuter forcément c'est
obligé mais mais en même temps ça nous
oblige à travailler et ça nous permet
aussi bas si on a des problèmes des
questions de demander directement à
l'image de jules et des autres 750 3148
candidats débute le bac lundi ces
révisions portons ont-elles leurs fruits
réponse le 6 juillet prochain c'était le
18 juin 2017 il devenait député de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines
bruno millet net avec nous sur le
plateau bonjour bonjour alors voilà
presqu'un an que vous êtes député modem
alors comment quel bilan vous faites de
cette première année je fais un bilan
d'une année studieuse où ça a beaucoup
travaillé il ya une raison à cela qui
est ce qui est très simple c'est que je
pense qu'entre le moment où emmanuel
macron une âme avant ça on va être
honnête ça commence avant et où il a été
élu et le moment où nous on a été élu il
ya eu quand même un mois et un peu plus
pour étudier la situation réelle du pays
on a eu quelques petites mauvaises
surprises et à partir de là on est sur
un quinquennat quand on voit l'état du
pays bien on a cinq ans pour réformer un
maximum de choses donc obligatoirement
obligé d'essayer de travailler le plus
rapidement possible et le mieux possible
de manière à engager les réformes
réellement de veiller à ce que les
résultats se voit assez rapidement parce
que l'impatience des français est énorme
or le président la république semble
réfléchir en ce moment sur la réforme
des aides sociales
le président a été dans son bureau
l'autre jour à l'elysée le préparer son
discours du congrès de la mutualité
française à montpellier une vidéo
publiée sur twitter ce mardi 12 juin je
vous propose de la regarder on bientôt
dans les minima sociaux
ils sont plein pot
on n'en sort pas mais on espérait tous
ceux qui tombent peau et reste pauvre
on a un truc il va nos gens s'en sortir
s'est reparlé de questions c'est comme
ça que ça le faire c'est ça qui fait
donc faut prévenir la pauvreté et
responsabiliser les gens vont qui semble
alors on le voit bruno myle yens
emmanuel macron semble douter de
l'efficacité actuelle de notre système
de protection sociale
comment réagissez vous face à cette
analyse alors d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier parce que vous avez montré
l'extrait quasiment en entier ce qui n'a
pas été le cas dans les différents
médias puisqu'on s'est contenté de la
première partie la réflexion du
président elle est simple et on l'a on
le honnêtement les politiques tous les
politiques le savent depuis longtemps on
a bien sûr qu'on a besoin d'être social
bien sûr qu'on a besoin d' allocation
pour les plus faibles
mais on a tout un entrelacs
d'allocations dont on ne sait pas
vraiment pourquoi elles sont faites
comment elles sont faites et qui font
que les gens qui savent très bien s'en
servir finalement et bien demain n'irons
pas chercher un boulot c'est pas vrai
vous allez pas aller chercher un boulot
vous allez gagner moins d'argent que ce
que vous touchez par le système
allocataires
donc c'est ça en fait qui veut dire donc
il faut il faut repenser tout ça il faut
vraiment mettre tout ça sur la table
repenser tout ça je sais pas quelles
sont les décisions qui vont être prises
mais je sais que nous au modem on est
favorable depuis très longtemps une
espèce d'allocations unique pour tout le
monde et puis surtout le la chose
primordiale c'est de donner aux gens de
quoi s'assumer donc la formation on y
vient la cense man discutent et
assemblée nationale l'éducation il en a
parlé c'est ce que c'est ce que fait le
ministre est très bien d'ailleurs
jean-michel blanquer avec l'éducation
nationale
il faut quand même il faut quand même
réussir à sortir les gens de cette
spirale de l'assistanat total assistanat
total vous l'avez dit vous parlez d'une
allocation unique est ce qu on pourrait
parler de revenu universel c'était la
proposition que choisit un danger là le
candidat ps benoît hamon à la
présidentielle je pense que ce sujet-là
reviendra sur la table je sais pas s'il
reviendra sur la table a maintenant
c'est un sujet récurrent mais c'est pas
la même chose que le revenu minimum
universel parce que le revenu minimum
universel par définition il est versé à
tout le monde que vous
les moyens de subsister ou pas nous et
des moyens de subsistance ou pas là ce
n'est pas le cas là c'est vraiment une
allocation parce qu'on peut pas laisser
les plus précaires sur le bas côté de la
route
il faut qu'on les aide donc il faut
qu'ils aient effectivement de quoi vivre
une allocation de quoi vu et que
derrière on arrive à les sortir de la
spirale pour le retrouver du boulot
c'est sa fin je sais pas si on parlait
de nouveau modèle social mais c'est ce
que devrait être le modèle social
français
c'est aider les gens qui sont vraiment
tombés du camion entre guillemets parce
que des accidents dans la vie tout le
monde peut en avoir
donc il faut les protéger les prémunir
contre la descente aux enfers et en même
temps il faut qu'on arrive à les
conduire vers de la reconversion un
emploi quelque chose qui donne sens à
leur vie qui donne une valeur réelle à
leur vie parce que je ne crois pas je ne
suis incapable d'imaginer je ne crois
pas que des gens qui vivent uniquement
des allocations soient fiers de vivre
des allocations
alors l'autre actualité de la semaine
c'est le vote en première lecture du
projet de loi est lent alors je rappelle
le projet de loi est lancé évaluation
portant sur l'évaluation l'aménagement
et les numériques d'évaluer l'évolution
du logement par dont l'aménagement et le
numérique
c'est un projet de loi qui a été adopté
en première lecture avec 342 voix pour
169 contre et 44 abstentions
et justement il semblant que vous êtes
vous soyez pardon abstenus sur ce texte
pourquoi je me suis abstenu pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
bonnes choses dont sedan ce projet de
loi je ne le nie absolument pas
simplement moi il me manque un volet
c'était le volet
territoire je trouve qu'on n'est pas
assez allé assez loin sur la
différenciation territoriale je peux
employer volontairement le terme de
ruralité les différentes stations
territoriales notamment au niveau de la
loi sru la loi sru est une espèce de
totem auquel on peut pas toucher je
trouve que c'est dommage je pense qu'il
faut qu'on applique la loi sru alors la
loi sru elle doit rester avec les fameux
25% alors juste rappeler justement la
loi sru c'est la loi solidarité
renouvellement urbain qui fixe le taux
de logements sociaux à 25 % pour les
communes de plus de 3500 habitants et un
seuil de 1500 habitants pour pour les
deux fronts d'île de france val a déjà
envoyé il ya une anomalie déjà ça c'est
une première anomalie 3500 partout en
france
1500 en ile de france je veux bien
l'entendre sur la partie urbaine et
périurbaine de l'île de france mais dans
les territoires dans lesquels nous
sommes nous bien je suis désolé 1500
c'est trop peu je connais beaucoup de
deux communes qui se sont retrouvés dans
l'obligation de construire des logements
très sociaux parce qu on leur adjoint
des hameaux autour d'un bourg centrale
donc ils ont passé le cap des 1500 et
qui n'ont ni le foncier ni les moyens ni
les infrastructures de pouvoir de
pouvoir construire ces logements là et
qui fait que finalement si vous faites
une étude
vous pouvez les construire les 250
logements sociaux une fois que vous avez
passé des 1500 mais pour autant ils
seront pas forcément occupé ces des
amendements que vous avez proposé dans
le cadre cette fois où ugly absolument
et le but c'était quad le but le but
c'est de dire voilà il ya quand même
donc dans tout aménagement du territoire
il ya un personnage clé en tout cas dans
l'est dans les départements et comme
chez nous dans tous les départements de
france via le préfet donc mettons nous
autour de la table avec le préfet qui
est garant de l'aménagement du
territoire et essayons de respecter la
loi dans son esprit c'est à dire les 25
% de logements sociaux mais adaptons là
à la réalité du territoire ne
construisons pas n'importe quoi
n'importe où ça c'est valable pour les
territoriaux mais c'est valable aussi
pour je pense à la commune des mureaux
par exemple ou ou un mantes la jolie qui
est pas forcé qui est pas celle sur ma
circonscription
mais as des as des as des villes comme
ça où passé un certain seuil de
logements très sociaux on perd la mixité
sociale
donc il ya un moment moi je pense qu'à
partir de 30 % de logements très sociaux
on devrait on devrait construire des
logements intermédiaires de manière
à faire revenir de la mixité sociale
dans les quartiers sinon on s'en sort
pas on fabrique quoi des ghettos alors
bruno milliers de rester avec nous on va
aborder les questions agricoles
on passe au résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine
lundi matin les agriculteurs ont lancé
un mouvement de blocage de raffineries
et dépôts de carburant dans toute la
france dans les yvelines le site de
coignières a été concerné par cette
mobilisation
leurs revendications la décision du
gouvernement d'autoriser total a importé
300 mille tonnes d'huile de palme d'asie
retour sur cette manifestation avec
nicolas kirillovitch les images sont
signés patrick jacques de dixmude des
tas de terre et de fumier déverser des
deux heures du matin à coignières et un
accès à la raffinerie rendu impossible
la fnsea et les jeunes agriculteurs ont
débuté cette nuit leur bras de fer
contre le gouvernement il s'oppose à
l'autorisation accordée à total pour
importés d'asie de l'huile de palme pour
eux ces livraisons promises pour
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle raffinerie
mettrait à mal la filière française de
biocarburants et ne respecterait pas non
plus les règles environnementales
on a eu tellement de choses qui nous ont
été re
qu'ils nous ont été reprochés au niveau
environnemental par les différents
gouvernements successifs
on s'y adapte systématiquement est
aujourd'hui en fait le gouvernement nous
fait un beau pied de nez matinale aussi
la réponse du ministre de l'agriculture
sur rtl stéphane travert indique que le
gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur
l'accord avec total pour lui ces
blocages sont illégaux depuis que
j'occupe ce ministère nous avons
toujours été dans une étroite
concertation dans le dialogue
mais ce dialogue il doit être franc moi
je dis qu'aujourd'hui ces blocages sont
sont illégaux et que ce n'est pas en
bloquant des raffineries que l'on
trouvera les solutions adéquates tout
simplement sujet environnemental
sensible au sein même de la majorité
il y a une dizaine de jours le député
yvelinois bruno myle yens interpeller
l'exécutif sur le sujet comment
aurions-nous peut nous poser en leader
mondial de la cause environnementale et
en même temps favoriser de telles
importations
la fnsea et les jeunes agriculteurs
prévoit pour le moment un blocage des
raffineries pour trois jours mais menace
déjà le mouvement sera reconduit
jusqu'au recul du gouvernement
un rendez vous est prévu demain au
ministère de l'agriculture
alors avant de vous faire réagir bruno
myle yens précisons que la fnsea et les
jeunes agriculteurs ont décidé de lever
les blocages mercredi soir après avoir
obtenu distille des garanties du
gouvernement après des heures de
négociations
alors on vous en tendant dans ce sujet
concernant les importations de l'huile
de palme vous contestez ses importations
n'y at il pas un décalage entre les
politiques du gouvernement par rapport
aux engagements environnementaux et les
engagements tenus auprès des
agriculteurs
là il ya vraiment oui effectivement là
il ya un décalage mange on va recycler
le si on a deux minutes on se situe le
contexte là le gouvernement honore un
engagement qui a été pris par le
gouvernement précédent de manuel valls
et de françois hollande
qu'un engagement qui était pris pour
total et pour préserver des emplois à la
mède hockey j'entends bien
pour autant je pense qu'on aurait pu se
trouver une autre solution
et dire ok on va produire des
biocarburants à la mède
on protège les emplois mais faisons ça
sur les filières oléagineuses françaises
et j'entends bien total aussi quand ils
disent oui mais les fraudes et filière
oléagineuse française c'est 20 % plus
cher que d'acheter de l'huile de palme
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on va qu'on
doit raisonner je pense que nos grosses
entreprises doivent être aussi
solidaires du mouvement environnemental
qui est en train de s'implanter partout
en france
on sait qu'on a besoin de lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique de préserver
la biodiversité et c'est pas en agissant
comme ça parce que malgré tout c'est de
la déforestation importés il faut savoir
quand même que du bio diesel à l'huile
de palme en termes de coût carbone
c'est trois fois plus cher pour la
planète que du diesel fossile donc à un
moment il faut il faut être cohérent
agriculteurs sur le terrain les
agriculteurs ils sont je pense qu'ils
ont plutôt satisfait de mes réactions
maintenant je leur ai dit aussi ils sont
pas étonné moi je me suis d'accord avec
eux sur le fond je n'étais pas d'accord
sur la forme
kaka prix de l'action même si
effectivement ils ont été reçus et
qu'ils ont obtenu quelques garanties
mais je préfère toujours mois la
discussion à la médiation à l'épreuve de
force brian meehan merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
député de la 9e circonscription des
yvelines
merci encore si vous passez un bon
week-end bien c'est également on
poursuit 7,8 hebdo avec ces inondations
plus de 50 millimètres d'eau sont tombés
en 12 heures aux mureaux ce mardi vous
le voyez à l'image l'autoroute a13 a été
coupée dans les deux sens de circulation
les secouristes sont intervenus plus de
mille fois dans le département
rambouillet la vallée de chevreuse le
sud du territoire n'a pas été épargnée
par la pluie avec parfois des
conséquences importantes
vous pouvez le voir l'affaissement d'un
talus a provoqué la sortie de voie d'un
rer b entre saint-rémy-les-chevreuse et
courcelles et sur yvette
sept personnes ont été légèrement
blessées le parquet de versailles a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire pour
déterminer les causes de l'accident
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines s'est engagé lundi pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
homme lui est ce qu a signé une
convention pour une communication
publique sans stéréotype de sexe une
convention accompagné d'une dizaine de
recommandations pour éviter par exemple
les affiches sexistes ou féminiser les
noms des métiers un reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch oublier les vieilles
expressions chef de famille ou
mademoiselle accorder les titres grades
et fonctions selon le sexe en signant
cette convention l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
souhaite lutter contre les stéréotypes
caché dans sa communication qu'elle soit
écrite ou visuel c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible qui touche les
étudiants qui touche les enseignants et
les personnels administratifs de pouvoir
avoir lorsqu'on fait par exemple des
fiches d'emploi des fiches de poste
d'avoir candidate candidats candidate
donc vraiment de d'essayer de faire tout
ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est à dire
de faire attention à qui on de pages en
ré pour espérer combattre efficacement
les stéréotypes le haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
propose au total la mise en place de dix
recommandations accord des métiers usage
du féminin et du masculin dans les
messages pour la communication visuelle
évitez les couleurs 12 pour les femmes
et les couleurs sombres pour les hommes
du bon sens pas encore des habitudes que
finalement le langage a été peu
questionné et on a peut questionner son
pouvoir sur les manières de penser et de
concevoir le monde sur les
représentations qu'on se fait des uns et
des autres et des unes et des autres
justement donc n'oublions pas dans
toutes les luttes qu'on a dans toutes
les démarches qu'on a pour promouvoir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de veiller à olemps gages qui est
utilisé en france seulement huit
universités se sont engagés en faveur de
cette convention
localement lu vs qu espèrent convaincre
certains de limite et c'est parti pour
un mois de compétition la coupe du monde
de football en russie s'est ouverte ce
jeudi dans les yvelines et supporters de
l'équipe de france sont prêts à pousser
derrière les bleus un engouement qui ne
cesse de monter un constat lors du
dernier entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine avant leur
départ en russie les images sont signés
michael
d'euros des autographes des photos des
échanges entre les joueurs et les
supporters ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à venir rencontrer les hommes
de didier deschamps à clairefontaine
l'accueil toujours extraordinaire qui on
est on est là pour la france un dernier
entraînement ouvert au public avant le
départ pour la coupe du monde en russie
les bleues ont pu constater la ferveur
autour de l'équipe de france passe voilà
on est soutenus non on est soutenus nous
avons en bois voilà toujours à tous de
rencontrer les supporters on passe un
bon moment avec elle nous permet de voir
tout le monde qui est derrière nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour mettre l'ambiance les bleus peuvent
compter sur les irrésistibles français
ce groupe de supporters créé en 2002
compte plus de 1000 adhérents parmi eux
ce couple de maurepas sylvain et
jennifer charvaux a pas la possibilité
d'aller en russie
donc on va leur montrer que nous mêmes
restant en france voilà on est là et on
sera toujours derrière quoi qu'il arrive
même ce parcours même si la ramène pas à
ses parents
[Applaudissements]
on a vécu
par jennifer et sylvain ont rejoint les
irrésistibles français pour l'ambiance
participation au match rencontre avec
les joueurs dédicaces des maillots de
nombreux souvenirs conservés on a
quelques autographes donc sur nos
divisions euros ici et de griezmann
ici le 12 juillet 98 c'était le plus
beau jour du foot français
vingt ans après ce titre ils attendent
une performance des hommes de didier
deschamps durant ce mondial avec
beaucoup d'émotion stressant énormément
stressant ça combine voilà comme chaque
coupe du monde chaque coupe d'europe on
aimerait la voir au plus haut au plus
haut comme en 98 revivre ces expériences
là c'est c'est magnifique et c'est pour
ça nous on se bat pour ça le foot nous
donne tellement de joie que c'est ça
vient une passion autour de ce sport
vécu en couple jennifer et sylvain reste
en france mais leur coeur bat pour les
bleus en russie on va la gagner
durant tout le week-end la commune de
villepreux accueille la 3ème édition du
festival de la photographie panoramique
une exposition organisée par
l'association villepreux images pixels
sur trois lieux différents
l'espace michel petrucciani la salle de
l'annexé la maison saint vincent
plus de 140 photographies sont à
découvrir
écoutez gilles fait organisateurs de cet
événement c'était dans le 7-8 culture de
mercredi dernier alors en fait la photo
panoramique déjà ça nous oblige les
imprimés parce que c'est vrai que
maintenant avec les téléphones et
smartphones les petits compacts beaucoup
de gens en prennent des photos soit ne
les regarde pas soit les mettre sur
leurs ordinateurs soient les maîtres
également sur les réseaux sociaux mais
davantage du panoramique pour que ce
soit vraiment intéressant
il faut l'imprimé c'est vrai que la
photographie avant tout c'est une
impression puisque une photographie
quand l imprimé sur un beau papier donne
un autre un autre pic et quand on dit au
niveau de la photo
donc on a pour votre information on a
par exemple une photo qui va faire plus
de 7 mètres et la plus petite sacra 60
cm
la remise des prix du concours aura lieu
dimanche 17 juin à 16 heures dans
l'espace michel petrucciani
pour plus d'informations concernant ce
festival vous pouvez vous rendez vous
pouvez retrouver ces informations sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran trap a accueilli mardi soir les
phases finales du 19e championnat
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale sur la scène de la merise
quatre collèges saint quentinois
ils se sont entraînés tout au long de
l'année le public était chargé de les
départager
retour sur cette soirée avec aurélie
rose yves christen berger et patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
la coordination
les collégiens
non
explosion de joie pour nathan marie
cyrine nicolas arthur et la lie ce sont
ces collégiens de coignières qui ont été
désignés par le public de la merise pour
remporter le trophée de cette 19ème
édition du cycle need organisé par
déclic théâtre une année de travail
récompensé on n'arrive pas à y croire
première année on gagne la première fois
du coup bah c'est super et je sais pas
comment expliquer l enthousiasme
c'est génial gang des femmes à barbe ou
encore un navire sans avenir
durant la soirée 4 collège de trappes et
long cours montigny le bretonneux et
coignières se sont affrontés sur ces
thèmes d'improvisation pour ces phases
finales quelques règles à respecter
comme la construction de l'histoire et
le respect de la langue française à la
fin de chaque passage le public donne
son verdict pour sa première
participation le collège la mare au sol
a remporté tous les suffrages
ils viennent là avec juste la folie du
jeu est en fait du coup ils sont
complètement détachée de l'enjeu et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence
[Musique]
on a une grosse énergie vient
véritablement dans les collèges et ça
c'est vraiment très intéressant et au
delà de cette énergie de la créativité
de l'imaginaire cette année le
championnat inter collèges
d'improvisation théâtrale a réuni 15
établissements de saint quentin en
yvelines une participation record qui
pourrait bien augmenter pour la
prochaine édition
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis si vous souhaitez
revoir cette émission en replay rendez
vous sur le site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 passer un
excellent week end
[Musique]